let's talk about Elizabeth Warren 2020
Democratic candidate Elizabeth Warren
has refused an invitation to do a town
hall on Fox News and there's a lot to
discuss here and I'm very interested in
many of the elements that are going on
here so you might remember that not long
ago weeks was it a couple months times
flying 2020 Democratic candidate Bernie
Sanders did a Fox News Town Hall and he
absolutely crushed it he had the entire
room clapping for Medicare for all he
schooled the moderators martha maccallum
and bret baier on everything from health
care to taxes to economics i mean really
just everything it went really really
well for Bernie Sanders and it went
really poorly for Fox News Elizabeth
Warren has been invited to do her own
Town Hall on Fox News and she's taking a
different approach she has turned it
down and she says Fox News is a hate
for-profit racket that gives a megaphone
to racists and conspiracists which of
course is completely true but there's
still a question of whether Elizabeth
Warren might benefit in the net by
appearing on fox news and talking about
what are mostly very good ideas that she
has as compared to ignoring Fox News
altogether now this is so funny there
are people attacking me on Twitter
already like I haven't even commented on
the Elizabeth Warren Fox News townhall
thing I'm commenting on it now and
people are tweeting me saying David you
are gonna be a hypocrite because you
praised Bernie Sanders for doing the
townhall and you're gonna praise
Elizabeth Warren for not doing the
townhall but remember what I said when
Bernie did the townhall is I think that
there are two legitimate perspectives
here do the Town Hall knowing that Fox
News is the propaganda arm of the Trump
administration because you're making the
calculation that you'd rather reach some
portion of their audience that is
convinced about
even though it's a total hate for-profit
racket as Elizabeth Warren points out
that's a legitimate idea legitimate
point of view it's also legitimate to
say I'm not going to implicitly or
explicitly give attention to this
propaganda network nor allow them to use
me
to continue their hate for profit racket
both are legitimate but you don't have
to take my word for it let's actually
look at what I said the day I covered
the Bernie Sanders town hall but there
were sort of two main arguments leading
up to this about whether Bernie Sanders
should or shouldn't appear the argument
against Bernie appearing is a very
simple one which is Fox News is the
propaganda arm of the Trump
administration it is not going to be a
hall that is sort of fairly set up it is
going to be an audience that is going to
have hand-picked people from political
groups including turning-point USA which
happened it's going to be one that most
likely will turn into a two on one sort
of argument between two Fox News
moderators and Bernie Sanders which it
did and it's a net loss don't give them
the ratings by appearing that was the
argument against Bernie appearing on the
other side the argument for Bernie
appearing is listen these are people who
otherwise may never even get a real
understanding from Bernie himself about
what his policies are most people not in
the physical audience but in the Fox
News television audience probably are
not going to be voting for the Democrat
in November of 2020 but if Bernie can
convince just one or two percent of the
people in the audience it's worthwhile
and he could reach people that otherwise
will never have anything break their
echo-chamber pierce their propaganda and
therefore it's worth Bernie appearing
both the respectable and defensible
points of view so again both their
legitimate strategies each candidate
should handle it how they see fit they
don't owe Fox News anything their
calculation should be what do they want
to do how do they want to use Fox News
if at all to push their agenda and to
push their platform and if they don't
want to do it that's perfectly
reasonable now there will be all of the
normal responses to Elizabeth Warren's
decision that we can imagine and and we
would expect Elizabeth Warren is scared
or she's avoiding debates and town halls
well Elizabeth Warren has done endless
town halls and she's faced countless
questions she recently took questions
completely unprepared when her plane
from I believe it was DC or LaGuardia
Charleston I believe it was got very
very delayed she held an impromptu Town
Hall she's faced questions from
adversarial people and people on her
side saying that in particular she
believes Fox News is a bad faith actor
is very different than saying she's
afraid of or won't participate in town
halls or adversarial interviews you also
have to consider and this is something
that I've not seen talked about since
this story broke given how poorly the
Bernie Sanders Town Hall went for Fox
News I mean a roomful of people clapping
for medicare-for-all
and clapping for Bernie Sanders on Fox
News that's not great for Fox News I
would be shocked if Fox allowed an
Elizabeth Warren Town Hall to go the
same way that the Bernie Sanders Town
Hall went my guess is that they would be
much more prepared to really make her
look bad in a way that they were unable
to make Bernie Sanders look bad now
Elizabeth Warren is smart enough and
quick enough that she still would
probably do okay but I think that that's
also probably a consideration in the
last seven days as you may have noticed
I have been pushed more and more in the
direction of Elizabeth Warren um I still
find her quite uncharismatic on a
personality level I don't see her really
connecting with large swaths of voters
particularly well but as I told you
yesterday her policy proposals are
detailed most of them I agree with
although I have some questions about
some of them and since the fiasco that
was the handling of her DNA test she has
been making many of the right decisions
and I would be glad to vote for her
against Donald Trump and I would be glad
to vote for Bernie Sanders against
Donald Trump as well many similarities
between the two important differences
which we've discussed but there are some
significantly good candidates that are
running right now on the Democratic side
and good for Elizabeth Warren and this
entire but by the way this may have
inadvertently had the very successful
popularizing of the term hate for-profit
racket about Fox News which has sort of
instantly been mainstreamed and has
appeared in all sorts of articles and
commentaries so
good for Elizabeth Warren good for
Bernie Sanders I respect both of their
decisions but I would like to hear from
you do you think Elizabeth Warren is
making the correct decision given all of
the circumstances or would you rather
see her do you think it would be the
right decision for her to do the Fox
News townhall let me know on Twitter at
D Pakman make sure you're following me
and follow the show as well at David
Pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be back after this
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
David Pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video